This is the first time I'm gonna be moving in with somebody since
my husband. You know what I mean?
Like, in that kind of way.
So, um,
teeny, tiny, small update on moving.
The boxes are still there,
but, um. Okay,
so since me and my boyfriend are moving in together,
and he works from home and I work from home,
we were like, let's try this out.
So we've literally been practicing,
and he's been, like,
staying here for multiple.
Because usually he would at least go home once a day or something.
Just spent all of our time together aside from, like,
the couple hours that he would go home.
But now he's been like, no,
I'm gonna, like,
do some laundry,
bring a few things over,
stay for a couple days,
and then I'll go home.
And I'm literally, like,
not seeing a problem.
We are just super easy,
get along. People that really just want peace and love
and are super happy and willing to work together to make that happen.
He calls me kids,
his roommates.
It's the cutest thing ever.
He's like, yeah,
my little rent free roomies.
Hey, hey.
It's adorable.
Um, it is truly, like,
making me, like,
fall, like,
a deeper level of love with him,
you know what I mean?
He's, like, respecting my wishes,
respecting me.
He's checking in with me.
It's not all about me.
I'm just saying, he's the here to speak his part.
And I can speak for him.
I'm just saying
for my experience as a single mom moving in with my boyfriend.
A boyfriend for.
I don't know. I'm super,
super, super into this.
I'm super excited.
I'm super. I'm super,
super looking forward to the future.